here's how to score genius on the
Cracker Barrel peg game every single
time first begin with an empty hole up
at the top then do what I call the
triangle Diamond whoa whoa wa wait
bottom Diamond method first we draw the
sides of this top triangle with jumps
side number one side number two and side
number three next we want this bottom
middle Peg to jump this diamond it can't
of course because it needs to have free
holes here so let's go ahead and free
those up just like this and and now the
bottom middle Peg can do the diamond
circuit all right we'll go
here we'll go here and then we'll go
here but before we complete the diamond
we wait and we do all the jumps we can
down here in the bottom row it doesn't
matter what order you do them in just
jump pieces on this bottom row until you
can't jump them anymore at this point
it's pretty clear what we do next we'll
jump down here taking that Peg away jump
over here removing this Peg and finally
we are left with just one peg